com'è l'inquadratura e vola agli ottavi
su una tavola carlos santana che tu
conosci bene così vasto e la chitarra
non l'ho mai toccata rimorchio che si
fanno vedere cosa sei sonar giulietta il
plettro che il plettro vetro e pokémon
crisi superate i ragazzi stiamo
registrando
questo è il giro di che
dimon demi non è quel qualcuno ha un po
che voleva l'elettro il tasto
d'accensione burcu demonio il paradiso
allora amore io ho bideau so che sei un
cagnolino dolce però ho bisogno di fare
le views che i cani fanno sempre un
sacco di persona qualcosa
e tu canto a qualcosa e facciamo le
brutte aspetta aspetta spettanza piene
le bis cod
[Musica]
[Applauso]
mamma mia
prendi
morena grazie
a parlare mentre
sì
[Musica]
s'intitola non so perché sei araba in
questo caso non so perché sei viola all
anno inizia in questo video da qui il
mondo faremo mai
è tutto uno e studiamo prendiamo cani e
chi turiamoci capelli li faccio viola
aspetta che mi spiego questo cane non
pesa niente non può essere vip non può
avere degli organi venderà esami e
melanzana non stavo scherzando non mi
devi mettere consiglio pedica non sto
scherzando il cei pensato sarà lo spray
sentirai un ragazzo melanzana o mio dio
però sei sicuro non è che si viene tanto
eh io non chiedo altro colore astengo e
maschere un altro volo ma che a me devi
parcobaleno è già un miracolo che io sia
mai bomba 6 passa quella roba simica
pelli meli cogode non è che i dati di me
sono state una star ha detto così anche
a montemagno anche questa cori
diventasse così bene questi sono
riformati milioni di ore è imposto
diventare pelato metà delle mie chiuso
sono dei miei capelli ma adesso epoca
veli descritti si lo so che adesso
secondo me sì ma guarda sono pronto per
andare in centro che iniziò a cantare
diventò famoso adesso si è adesso tutto
questo è il karma dovrebbe essere un
quality mi serve un parrucchiere
chiamatemi giulia per carità di dio
riceverà il mio telefono così la prendo
io lo prendevo la passione oggi siamo
qui perché con questi capelli vogliamo
testare di nostro paziente in pelle con
idea è questa
ecco in due secondo me a tre cifre non
ci arriviamo
ma cos'è si chiama trivia crack tu
conosci bene solo la seconda parte del
nome che pensa se io mi drogassi come
terreni dove l'odore del sesso che hai
addosso
noi abbiamo radio che non risponderò
alla preservati queste domande non
significa che io sia stupida
solo che i capelli viola quello che
influisce sull'intelletto in che squadra
gioca al 2017 il calciatore paolo di
barra fortunatamente io questa la sapevo
juventus va bene a cannes adesso giulia
tocca a te quale automobili è stata
creata da adolf hitler
questa la sai lo so che la saletta dice
capelli giaccherini
evviva corretto marco prova director
fagen in tedesco come detto prima
xmarks fucking è scusato molto tangibile
ma si fa così era fusa in ogni anno
esatto le scartoffie cosa vuol dire
cartocci accartoccia e non lo so vuol
dire patate guardi per le quali pesce è
conosciuto per non lari controcorrente
marco goloso il salmone salmone bravo ma
i manicomi ma non vale dobbiamo
sbagliare perché in questi anni dall
ultimo video da mou fatto studiato ossia
tutto avevo pubblicamente preso in giro
ma non ne volete quei media quanto mi
piacerebbe venisse bello veramente
perché l'attore protagonista di cambia
la tua vita con un click
lo sai che io non so il papa ci
risponderà te perché non è possibile
caso chiami alla testa con un click
emma watson tale da un san paolo che
cambiano la sapevo se è un bel film o
chi è protagonista di ge intera p.ti
protagonista di un mafioso e mai
macchiato la maglia quali furono le
prime nazionali a contendersi acute
io racchiude il video non può essere
così per uno store resto lì non puoi
come puoi stessa risponde alla domanda
se sai neanche leggere riguardo
intendersi una finale di coppa italia
brasile
porca l'oca hai azzeccato la risposta ma
non hai abbracciato la domanda b quando
inizia la seconda guerra mondiale sempre
del materiale lei sta cercando la fuga
tipo prison break
poverina allora quando inizia la seconda
guerra mondiale la seconda guerra
mondiale inizia nel 39 per la geografia
oggi o peggio grafia proprio c'è una
cartina manuele cosa da piccola dove si
svolge la battaglia delle arance durante
il carnevale io lo so dove la mater
arance il carnevale di rio de janero a
ivrea hi bred dove sono nato io vicino
lito ci fanno dire tante ricordiamo è
già nero e ivrea ne vorrebbe recarsi la
tua finita la mia timpani le strisce ma
sei scema no in quella vecchia vinta
grazie che meglio si chiamavano di
scusami ma che non me la vedo ma adesso
mi sto lavando lei che il cane sta
cliccando magari perché io ero un sacco
del cambio girato e mi sa di che no
queste tua michele ama calcio tra che
altra modiche regione tipico vino
lambrusco lambrusco
toscana chianti la toscana ha bei
ragazzi e il vino che io devo sui
capelli e bar appunto da ma va avanti
basta cosa sta in casa viola smith in
amica che a brutte figure ma non vuol
dire essere le armi e malika le persone
che ordine sono le colonne del parte
donne che vogliono agli sbagli i colori
capelli di un altro colore pronto
corinzio sbagliato ma io lo abbiamo
convinto fosse corinzio delle colonne
del parte no non erano corinzie ha
sbagliato ragazzi usiamo un po di blu
adesso perché lei ovviamente sapeva che
erano corinthia ecc
non sappiamo sarà attuato carinzia no no
non può scendere minerale scelto v6 da
che giurano che mi sento di satana nei
capelli quando ero bambino mi mettevo la
colla nei capelli ecco sto rivivendo
quel momento del loro bellissimo guardai
posso andare a casa così mia madre che
ti dico la rabbia è stampato tena tu lo
sai chandra volta di un'altra volta che
fanno il remake della febbre sabato sera
che chiamano john travolta chiamano john
schifo ma ora viola come contenta
l'ultima in due
che squadra ha vinto la champions league
nel 2012 per la prima volta the real
madrid si è ripopolata l'ha inventata ad
arrivare in champions
cessi all'ultimo secondo me l'ha mai
sentito chelsea all'ultima vero male mai
schiacciato i ragazzi che possiamo
terminare questo video perché giulia è
stato appunto brava e non pensavo non
pensavo non perché amo domiziana perché
io in genere faccio molto schifone quiz
io spero credo vi sia piaciuto io non mi
abbasserò mai più a fare una questione
del genere per i comuni no con i miei
capelli sono persone non c'è bisogno di
secondo per fai clic
però io mi hanno fatto se dovete
piaciuto ragazza mi date un po di like
quanti ne vuoi 100.000 like per i miei
capelli grazie al 2000 condividete il
video con vostra nonna aggiunge idem ea
me sul mio canale youtube e di storia vi
sia piaciuto ragazzi quasi sempre
cercato in piazza cavalli sociale di
visita sono resistenti non ci vediamo
ciao e quindi ragazzi questo era ok
ringrazio tantissimo giulia per aver
partecipato e l'abbiamo registrato
proprio in freestyle e cioè proprio
compito così giusto per sparare un paio
di cagate comunque volevo dirvi che sul
canale di giulia che mi lasci
descrizione è uscito mio video con lei
che si chiama spaghetti e musica che la
rubrica di giulia se passate le date le
views che se le merita un pochino perché
è stata una vita a montare quel video io
feci per montare questo ci ha messo poco
la roba dei capelli visto che tutti me
lo chiederanno
ci ho messo due ore per togliere tutta
quella roba non è stato divertente sia
per cento ragazzi non si sono certamente
a cercare italiani se non esiste
[Musica]